hey guys how's it going it's Justine and
today we are doing very interesting
unboxing some of you may have seen that
I was on Good Morning America not too
long ago I was on the show talking about
Walmart's Black Friday deals and it was
the best time ever and in front of me in
beside me are a few of the things that I
talked about on the show Black Friday
starts on Walmart calm on 1121 at 10
p.m. in store starts on Thursday 11 22
at 6:00 p.m. before we get into these
items there's also a Walmart calm apps
you can download the app ahead of time
you can make a game plan for what the
things are that you want to get in store
it'll give you a map so you'll easily be
able to find all of the things when you
actually get there and it's time to
start shopping so now let's get into
checking out some of these items these
were a few of the highlights that I saw
on their list of Black Friday deals that
they have you guys know I love video
games so these are two console bundles
that they have both of these are $1.99
this is a PlayStation 4 spider-man
bundle and this is the Xbox one s this
is the Minecraft edition it's obviously
with both of these you do get the games
the controller and the console I'm not
gonna unbox these because you've already
seen me unbox Playstations and Xboxes
before we need to get in to these
mystery eggs this is the hatch of babies
I have not even seen these before I had
a hatch amol last year and I refuse to
let it hatch like if anybody touched my
hatch amol that was sitting on my mantle
I'm like no don't do it I think that
this year I'm gonna let this one
actually hatch so the Black Friday deal
for this guy is 3488 ding ding ding I'll
take 2 unboxing toys it makes me feel
like a kid again
look these are off this is so exciting
like next video I shattered my hatch
Amol
a little pony stand to put your egg in
hello I'm your new mom that's that's a
rocking horse is it crying hey are you
okay in there so next up we have Ryan's
giant mystery egg and this actually
holds a very special place in my heart
because Ryan is a fellow youtuber he
does toy unboxings and reviews and I
love his channel I love everything that
they've created with Ryan and what's
special about this there is one lucky
egg that contains a golden ticket that
will allow you to go and meet Ryan being
an unboxing video of his it has all
kinds of fun little mystery things slime
putty squishy plush two figures lights
and sounds a vehicle call for 3480 to
Black Friday deals
coming in hot oh my goodness there's a
lot of things in here this is a premium
egg is this when they send a vehicle I
thought like a little tiny car oh no
this is a flying saucer I'm gonna have a
character to go in here there's a
mystery slime you can collect them all
oh gosh clutching things you see me
cruise around Walmart was like fifty
eggs in my bathroom trying to collect
all of these characters whoa it's
squishy when they said squishy like I
read the words but I didn't visualize it
being this squishy alien this all makes
sense and right this is like the egg
that doesn't stop hatching again the
giant mystery egg of Ryan's is $34 and
82 cents and next up we've got another a
little mystery thing this is the wool
surprise pearl surprise Black Friday
deal is 2988 it's got its nice little
sticker here that says peel here oh
let's talk about impeccable packaging
hey over here
me first oh my gosh I get it this isn't
an egg that's why these are pearls
you're getting a surprise pearl let's
see what we have in here what
is this this is the most massive bath
bomb that I have ever seen in my entire
life
this is like a bath bomb that you would
throw in your swimming pool don't vote
in your swimming pool because I'm pretty
sure your parents will get very upset
with you little shoes there's a bikini
shirt
another little bikini where's the body
where's the fire support camera what are
you pointing at it the body is in the
bath bomb oh my gosh all right well
we're gonna have to cut to that just
that bomb in the bath my gosh the moment
that we've been waiting for her this all
makes so much more sense now this is
probably one of my favorite deals this
is the pac-man retro arcade of course
all of these things as a reminder
because if you've never shot Black
Friday they are while supplies last so
definitely do your best to be first in
line or first online are you guys ready
because I'm going to turn this thing on
it's gonna warn you it's really loud
Roback game i feel like this is
something that would be great for
collectors or really I mean honestly
anybody I wonder how many kids out there
have never even feel like they've
probably heard it back in right I don't
know oh that's the terrible terrible sad
sounds the game over well thank you guys
so much for watching I hope that you
guys enjoyed this video this was so much
fun and I think that my new hobby is now
gonna be opening mystery eggs maybe I
should start like a second or third or
fourth channel for my new hobby and
again Black Friday starts on walmart.com
on 1121 at 10 p.m. Eastern and in stores
Thursday 11:20 to 6 p.m.
whatever your local time is well thank
you guys again let me know does anything
else you'd like for me to check out and
if you did catch the Good Morning
America segment leave me a comment below
and let me know I'll see you later bye
oh gosh I've slowly new toys to play
with I'm gonna dog
[Music]